[Musique]
le premier défi à nos habitudes
téléspectateurs et pour demain et c'est
canal+ qui le lance canal+ à partir du 4
novembre prochain pourra être captées
dans une bonne partie du pays et ensuite
dans la france toute entière
voici le générique qui sous certaines
conditions va entrer dans vos habitudes
[Musique]
oui
oh
[Musique]
où
pierre lescure bonsoir vous êtes un
directeur des programmes de canal +
alors qu'est ce que vous nous proposez à
part ce générique pour nous allécher
oui un générique qui est une forme de
jingle de bande qui passe en ce moment
tous les après midi de 14 heures à 18
heures pour tous ceux qui peuvent déjà
capté canal+ que proposeront nous à
partir du 4 novembre
eh bien d'abord des programmes qui
seront diffusés 20 heures sur 24 du
lundi au vendredi et 24 heures sur 24
les programmes non-stop
durant le week-end ces programmes sont
composés en bonne partie de cinéma
puisque à 40%
le programme proposé est composé le film
il y a six films inédits à la télévision
par semaine chaque film un inédit par
jour six jours par semaine étant
programmé six fois en 14 jours j'insiste
là dessus et pas moyen de manquer la
baie vous le dit avec le sourire
christine mais ce soir s'il y avait un
film sur canal+ vous seriez en train de
le manquer et si ce film était network
par exemple ça vous intéresserait le
voir un peu les aventures de cette jeune
femme est bien ici une pierre escurat
des solutions originales sur canal plus
bas toute émission nouvelle étant sûre
d'elle même original vous savez je crois
vraiment si j'insiste sur les films et
sur la multidiffusion c'est que ce n'est
pas à vous que je dirais qu'on
n'explique pas on ne raconte pas la
télévision
si je vous dis on va faire des émissions
de variétés bien sûr que je nous
essayons de faire en sorte qu'elle soit
le plus varié possible si l'on fait des
cylons propose des musiques j'espère
qu'elles seront les plus musical
possible la télévision ça se vit au
quotidien
ces quotidiens et domestiques en
revanche ce qui existe déjà
ce sont les films parce qu'ils ont déjà
une histoire en eux mêmes alors d'ores
et déjà grâce au mailing proposition
d'abonnement envoyé par correspondance
et qui viennent de partir à plusieurs
millions d'exemplaires à travers la
france les premiers films sont connus
alors je peux dire par exemple que la
programmation cinématographique elle ira
de de l'as des as pour le mois de
novembre à identification d'une femme en
passant par danton ou pour la peau d'un
flic c'est une programmation assez
hétérogène parce qu'on veut s'adresser
un maximum de public mais si j'insiste
sur la multidiffusion c'est que je crois
que le caractère non pas concurrentiel
mais complémentaires de canal+ c'est
cette capacité
et que nous essayons de donner à
l'abonné de consommer plus facilement le
programme qui lui est donné car si
programmation de cinéma en 14 jours
toujours à des heures différentes
cela vous permet si vous regardez canal
+ 1 lundi du matin au soir de ne jamais
retomber deux fois sur une programme ou
si vous regardez tous les soirs à partir
de 21h jusqu'à 3 heures du matin canal+
vous ne retomberaient jamais deux jours
de suite sur le même programme
vous pouvez consommer quand vous voulez
père explique ont quand même que canal+
est en france avec la bénédiction des
pouvoirs publics
la première illustration concrète de
l'abandon du monopole et ça c'est
nouveau et cela en vertu du monopole de
diffusion en vertu de la loi de 82 alors
qu'à côté des trois chaînes du service
public
ce sera donc une télévision à péage une
télévision payants et qui utilise les
voies de transmission traditionnel
c'est-à-dire par voie hertzienne
laurent broomhead ce qui signifie
christine qu'il faudra une antenne
salaires stupide mais si je vous en
parle c'est parce qu'actuellement vous
recevez antenne 2 avec une antenne uhf
et hf car la fréquence et eu à chef
or canal+ avec la plupart de ces
émetteurs et mettra en vhf c'était avant
la télévision en noir et blanc qu'on a
recyclé pour la circonstance en couleurs
alors donc si vous avez une antenne
plutôt anciennes ou pro commande pas
celle-là elle ira elle marchera très
bien en revanche vous avez une antenne
toute nouvelle et bien peut-être que
vous aurez quelques adaptations à faire
enfin et bien ma foi si vous êtes prêt
d'un émetteur vous pouvez tout
simplement vous contenter d'une antenne
de table et ça marchera très bien
maintenant vous avez l'antenne il vous
faut l'image vous apercevez que cette
image elle est cryptée cryptée c'est le
terme idoine il va donc falloir
décrypter avec un décrypteurs le voici
voici la bête qui vous coûtera 420
france et une caution de 400 enfants qu
on vous rembourse
comme toute caution sauf si vous ne
prenez aucun engagement de six mois là
on vous donnera seulement la moitié
et puis vous faudra payer 120 francs que
voici pour ses 120 francs on vous
donnera un show codes différents
personnels pour vous est différent
chaque mois ce code personnel à 8
chiffres vous l'introduire est dans la
machine avec ses touches et donc votre
image apparaîtra en clair sur l'écran
troisième étape
si maintenant vous voulez enregistrer
image alors d'abord une première chose
si vous voulez enregistrer de tf1
antenne 2 fr3 tout en regardant canal+
pas de problème ça marche très bien
comme d'habitude si maintenant vous
voulez enregistrer canal + 1 et films
dont parlait pierre lescure et bien
c'est un peu plus complexe d'abord il
faut un raccord spéciale pour brancher
le magnétoscope aux décodeurs et puis
surtout il faudra que ce décodeur soit
branché et le téléviseur allumé sur
canal+ si vous m'avez bien suivi ça
signifie que vous pourrez enregistrer
canal+ met à les chaînes de télévision
en même temps en même temps que vous
regardez les chaînes de télévision tf1
antenne 2 fr3 vous êtes condamnés à
regarder canal + pour l'enregistrer
évidemment l'argument en la circonstance
c'est que les films passant six fois en
quinze jours vous c'est à vous de vous
débrouiller pour trouver un créneau
vous pouvez donc enregistrer ce film au
total si on ajoute le prix de l'antenne
les 420 francs remboursable
les 120 francs par mois et les
accessoires canal+ n'est pas gratuit il
va donc falloir que les programmes
soient vraiment au niveau
alors pierre canal puis ce n'est pas
gratuit mais canal+ va coûter combien
aux téléspectateurs parce que c'est
finalement cela qui nous intéresse est
plus l'échéance approche plus on lit de
ci de là des des factures finalement
très différents ses 2500 francs ou 5000
francs non mais quelle qu'elle est
l'éventail des chiffres écoutez si
aujourd'hui un tel cas on vient de faire
une addition qui paraît exorbitantes et
on a pris l'addition maximale pour le
téléspectateur potentiel le plus mal
loti
mais si aujourd'hui cette antenne
correspond à peu près aux normes qui
évoquait laurent broomhead vous en
coûtera rien vous paierez donc 120
francs par mois soit 4 francs par jour
pour 20 heures de programmes
effectivement c'est plus cher que le
service public on a toujours dit que
c'était une chaîne à péage faut pas se
cacher alors deuxièmement 4 francs par
par jour donc la caution du décodeur qui
vous est rendu pour moitié si vous vous
abonnez simplement pour six mois donc si
vous n'êtes pas contents si vous
interrompez l'abonnement pour le reste
c'est vrai que l'antenne si elle doit
être adaptée coûtera de l'argent combien
une antenne individuelle coûte 550
francs une antenne collective coûte 2500
francs tu divises
et par le nombre d'appartements
effectivement si vous habitez un hôtel
particulier avec deux locataires ça vous
fait un peu cher si vous habitez dans un
immeuble avec 15 ou 20 locataires ça
fait déjà beaucoup moins cher autre
rendez vous autrement dit une addition
très variable finalement ça coulait en
moins sur nos magnifiques mais des
hausses coop que nous monter laurent
baumel alors largement en tout cas cela
coûtera son prix est alors pour ce prix
qu'est ce que vous allez offrir de neuf
au téléspectateur est déjà un corps gras
ils sont appelés à des chaînes de
service public qui franchement coûte
très peu cher je crois que ça représente
à peu près à quoi deux francs par par
foyer vous faites une magnifique
émission sur l'explosion de
l'audiovisuel vous ne voulez pas quand
même qu'on annonce que tout explose mais
qu'en plus ça coûte pas un centime de
plus l'explosion des moyens audiovisuels
c'est comme l'explosion de l'épicerie
fine ça coûte cher mais c'est ça coûte
cher
ces doutes sont pris dans l'épicerie
fine ira le caviar les films nommés on
t'a pas dans le caviar les films tels
qu'on les a proposés j'estime que c'est
à la fois plus performant et plus
pratique
il ya du sport en exclusivité l'accord
vient d'être pratiquement conclu avec la
ligue du football professionnel pour les
25 matches de championnat en direct par
saison il y a effectivement des shows et
un certain nombre de rendez-vous mais
qu'une fois de plus je suis obligé de
vous dire que c'est pas pour conserver
des secrets je répète qu'en dehors des
films qui ont déjà une vie en eux mêmes
ou les rencontres sportives qui sont
déjà programmés pour le reste bien sûr
que je pense que les séries qu'on va
proposer les feuilletant qu'on va
proposer seront particulièrement
performant mais je trouve tout à fait
logique que vous comme tous ceux qui
nous regardent considère qu'il faudra
juger sur pièce parce que la télévision
ça se vit et donc ce sera la surprise à
partir du 4 novembre
un mot encore sur vos sur vaud
finances vous n'avez pas droit à la
publicité donc vous avez d'une part ce
que vous rapporteront les abonnements
non bien celui vous avez aussi le
mécénat c'est à dire que les entreprises
qu'ils sont intéressés peuvent parrainer
des émissions pour un tarif est sûre et
les entreprises sont intéressées à cette
forme nouvelle de promotion des rimes à
écouter je ne veux pas vendre la peau de
l'ours avant l'heure il est évident que
aujourd'hui un grand nombre de très
grosses firmes se sont proposés pour
sponsoriser les marques elles se sont
proposés parce que comme toutes les
grandes firmes qui ont des budgets de
promotion important elle veut être
elles veulent être du départ resteront
tels avec nous oui suivre ainsi en a
marre si on marche bien mais pour
l'instant sincèrement pour le sponsoring
ça va bien et alors marché bien en
termes d'audience votre première cible
alors c'est quoi toutes les enquêtes que
nous avons menées jusqu'ici atteste que
nous devrions effectivement avoir un
potentiel de 200 milles décodeur de cent
mille abonnés de cent mille foyers au
démarrage entre le 4 et le 30 novembre
l'objectif est effectivement d'atteindre
500 mille abonnés au printemps prochain
et 800000 qui est notre point
d'équilibré à la fin 1985
c'est l'hypothèse je ne dirais pas
optima mais assez réaliste qui a été
établi en fonction tous les tests
effectués jusqu'ici par les équipes de
la logistique baptême donc le 4 novembre
le 4 novembre découverte des émissions
de canal plus
[Musique]